[Music]
before the 20th century people knew
about two basic forces
the gravitational force and the
electromagnetic force
but in the course of the 20th century
when they started to study
atoms and their interiors it became
clear that those forces
were not the whole story and in
particular one needed
a very powerful force to hold atomic
nuclei together because
gravity is much too weak and the
electromagnetic forces in fact want to
want to explode nuclei they're repulsive
so it came to the top of the agenda to
determine what this force is
we were fortunate enough to glom onto
what turned out to be the key
that opened this door uh which is that
people had observed that the the
strong force had a very unusual
character of becoming
weaker at high energies or at short
distances
this idea is very unusual
it's not the way gravitational forces
work they get stronger it's not the way
electromagnetic forces work they get
stronger at shorter distances
and it was very difficult to reconcile
that behavior with the general
principles
that we thought of as sacred of
quantum mechanics and and relativity so
we struggled to find a theoretical
framework a set of equations that
reconciled all those things those two
those basic principles and this funny
behavior
and we found that there was basically
just one way to do it and so we proposed
that that was the theory of the strong
interaction
we were right they got the right
equations and they've been very fruitful
they've enabled us to
understand the early universe better to
understand
what happens at high energy accelerators
are much better
and to have some success in constructing
a way of unifying all the forces
[Music]
some outstanding examples of beauty and
physics that are close to my heart
are the equations that govern the strong
interaction
so-called quantum chromodynamics which
is
almost ideally mathematically beautiful
it's an embodiment of
symmetry the whole structure of the
theory is dictated
by very simple mathematical principles
another is axions where we're led
by small violations of symmetry that
have been observed to
a certain way of trying to explain why
they're small
that leads to very special equations
that have remarkable properties
and part of the beauty is the equations
part of the beauty is that
they may explain so much about how the
world works
so these are remarkable instances where
mathematical
abstract beauty also turns out to be
powerfully applied to describe reality
i do probably several times a day think
about the deep structure of everyday
things that i'm encountering
and it really enhances my experience of
even of everyday life my new book is
called fundamentals
10 keys to reality so my goal here is to
present
the most basic conclusions and attitudes
and
and uh relationships
that we can have with the physical world
based on
the best hard-won knowledge
that that we've accumulated i would say
two of the highlights for me that i sort
of discovered
in writing the book are the concept that
to come into proper relationship with
reality you have to be born again
babies when they start to experience the
world
have to make models for even the most
basic things of
how do you construct a three-dimensional
world picture that you can move around
in and know that there are separate
objects
uh that has to be learned and it's a
difficult process when you study the
world scientifically
you learn that the world is actually
quite different than the one
you constructed as a child and so
you have to unlearn things and i call
that a process of being born again
the question that was central to my
previous book a beautiful question was
does the world embody beautiful ideas i
considered that very seriously from
different points of view and came to
what i think is a convincing answer yes
and maybe the most
convincing evidence of that is that
equations
that we propose based on idea
aesthetic ideas of what would be the
most
balanced economical symmetrical possible
description
of of a situation turn out to be the
correct equations
so it turns out that the operating
system that governs the world
is something we can also appreciate
aesthetically not just
as a manual so to speak